please to have any old check back here
in the Rich Eisen show how you doing
Eddie rich I'm better for talking to you
talk let's let's chat about this now man
game 1 what was it like being that arena
in Las Vegas Las Vegas Nevada
man just off the charts I mean I've been
coming here since I was 18 years old for
for pleasure and getting my feet wet in
a lot of different ways and I mean the
town is absolutely up for grabs rich
it's it is hockey crazy it is Vegas
Golden Knights crazy and you know you
got you got blackjack dealers wearing
jerseys you got pit bosses wearing
jerseys you got the MGM lion outside the
hotel with a bit Jersey the Statue of
Liberty outside the New York New York
the Red Rock Resort in Hotel and Casino
they got all their employees are wearing
gold and nights of it it is just awesome
and it's their own rich right like it's
not a team coming from City a B or C and
this team has just I mean it's
galvanized the community and they become
a part of the fabric and the game one
was just I'm I was off the charts long
it was just absolutely incredible game
on well I want to ask you the same
question I've asked you know everybody
who's come on the show on the on the
subject from Barry Melrose to to
everybody who I've had on from the Vegas
Golden Knights yeah you know how did how
did this happen yeah you know what I
think you George McVie the general
manager had a plan and they identified a
certain type of player a certain athlete
that they wanted to bring into the mix
and if anybody thinks that this was
concocted or this was the plan by the
league that it was rigged a certain way
please wait come on you give your see a
doctor the rules were implemented the
expansion draft happened in the general
manager George McPhee went out and
played a game of poker with a bunch of
general managers and a National Hockey
League and pretty much won every hand
that he played and when you bring in
certain type of players and they come in
have this feeling of okay well my
opportunity wasn't in City a I'm gonna
give it the opportunity here and all
these guys use that you know as a
motivator and you got the guy in goal
who had won three Stanley Cups and
marc-andre flurry a terrific coach and
Gerard go on they wanted to play a
certain way and look from day one they
played the same exact way to where they
are right now three wins away from the
Stanley Cup and look if if people or
other teams don't like it well you know
what do something about it beat them LA
had a chance to beat them they lost four
straight San Jose had a chance rich they
lost in six Winnipeg had a chance they
lost in five so nothing is given to
anybody and this team has burnt
everything and they deserve to be where
they are I can't I still can't believe
it I mean it's an incredible story if
they're not the sports team of the
decade shame on everybody because this
has just been a movie in the making
considering what they've been able to
accomplish and and how they've really
galvanized this community yeah my
favorite line that I heard on this very
subject Eddie I'm with any Olczyk of NBC
Sports was from George McVie himself we
had him on at the day after they beat
the Winnipeg Jets to make Stanley Cup
Finals and he basically said anybody who
in the league was complaining about the
rules they all accepted the 17 million
dollar expansion check from our home you
know it was really just a the rules are
the real the rules were put in place and
again maybe some players make I like
William Carlsen he's 43 goals this year
you know we had six in Columbus balloon
so you know look just sometimes I'm
again I was traded enough over my
16-year career in the league rich so
sometimes opportunities close and then
when you're traded another opportunity
opens up and you had all these players
that you know teams didn't want and
again I'm sure and I know this from
talking to Joe Mathers around the league
is that George McPhee
you know bluffed a couple of teams and
said look you know we like we like
player a when they really did it so they
knew who they wanted to get and then
they end up getting draft picks along
with the players that they accumulated
and it's just it's an incredible story
it's the
way to really put it and hard to believe
is that their their three wins away from
winning a Stanley Cup in their very
first year existence that's right and
the caps opportunity knocking for
Ovechkin and that team as well what do
you think the adjustment is this evening
I mean do they need even make one I mean
they were up for three yeah in Game one
what what do you think about tonight's
game two on NBCSN when the puck drops
hold Eastern yeah well I think before I
get into the adjustments the one thing I
will say rich is going back to Game one
it's four to three John Carlson the
defenseman for the caps hits the post
okay could easily made it 5-3 but it did
it and then shortly after that Carlson
gets cross-checked from behind in front
of his own that Ryan Reeves was the
Vegas goal tonight gets the puck goes
top shelf ties the game the goal should
not accounted there should have been a
penalty
it was missed by the officials that's
the way that it goes give Vegas credit
they took advantage and then late in the
game when they were trailing five before
that being the caps Laura Zeller had a
wide open net and he just kind of his
momentum got broken concentration got
broken by a great stick vibrate and
McNabb so the the window was open for
Washington it really was now in saying
what will be the adjustments I don't
know if they want to get into one of
those games at six four five three rich
I don't think so I think they got to get
back to playing the way they did when
they eliminated Pittsburgh in Game six
and how they played against Tampa the
first couple of games and then of course
late in that series against Tampa it's
got to be tight it's got to be five guys
back in the middle of the ice way for an
opportunity to jump to the other way I
don't think you want to be getting a
shootout with Vegas because they you
know they relish that type of game and
look Washington doesn't mind playing
that but you got to pick your spots you
got to be more selective in both goalies
I would expect to be way better than
they were in Game one because I think
both cold tenors were you know we're
below average at best in Game one few
minutes left with any old check here on
the Rich Eisen show you think Tom Wilson
should have been suspended for that hit
on March or so Eddie
very close I I don't think I don't think
a suspension I think for sure a penalty
and look it took the officials a while
but they got it right it was a late hit
could I see them get a five-minute
interference call yeah I could have seen
that I would not have a problem with
that I don't think it was late late
where I would have given them a
suspension but to me the referees
initially
they hauled it up they got some help and
they made the right call and to me at
the end of the day that's all that
matters but I could argue a five-minute
penalty without question but I I would I
would not have suspended them on the hip
well the thing that I've been talking
about obviously having with an NFL
background here fairness chair is the
concept of defenseless player okay in
the air F and the NFL that would have
definitely been a fine from from the NFL
the NFL will definitely be taking some
money from a player for a hit like that
do you think the NHL should do that from
someone from Tom Wilson if not make
something like that a suspend a ball hit
for somebody who's got a rap sheet like
Wilson already has in these playoffs and
while there are there are rules in place
and yes with it with the you know with
the fines and it's it's limited to what
they've you know collective David you
know the but collective bargain
agreement that they've you know agreed
on the number and what-have-you but you
know for me I think it's it's it's one
of those plays that yeah I'd like to see
it eliminated from the game and the only
way you're gonna eliminate it rich is be
much stiffer on the penalty and I if you
think it's a suspend a bull hit you say
look when you're tracking a guy from The
Blind Side and he did he moves the puck
well ahead of you know cuz again hockey
is a fast game football is a fast game
guys changed her angle guys change their
level stuff happens contacts gonna
happen guys are going to get hit in the
head it's just inevitable but when you
think you can avoid that type of hit now
could Tom Wilson have avoided that hit
on Marcia so absolutely but what's the
deterrent rich what is the deterrent is
it five game suspension is that ten game
suspension is it $100,000 fine trust me
guys will think twice if they know
exactly what it is look I think the
league is cut the NHL has come a long
way when it comes to the rules and in
implementing fines and suspensions I
think they've done a really good job and
it's always going to be subjective
without question but until it is black
and white when you say you know you
track a player and you go ahead and come
from a blind spot and you drill them
late or you hit them in the head late or
you hit them in the head and that's
what's targeted until there's those
paym suspensions and it's black and
white when I'm talking about the
suspension I'm not talking clays because
there are you know black and white is
not the way that professional sports is
but for me is that if you can implement
something where players know what is the
deterrent and I use that word in capital
letters if there's a deterrent players
will be less apt to go ahead and take
advantage of a player that's in a really
rough spot we like hockey we want we
know I know the difference we know the
difference between hockey plays hockey
plays that go bad and in guys just being
selfish and we want to get rid of the
selfish place last one for you Eddie
ten days until yeah the Belmont Stakes
do you think justify pulls it off the
Triple Crown I do I do I think he is I
think he is the horse I don't think a
mile and a half is going to be a problem
he's got the best trainer in the world
and Bob Baffert so for me a mile and a
half race in the Belmont or any long
horse race rich being a huge fan and a
handicapper and playing the horses since
I was 14 years old
those long-distance races are at jockeys
race and he's got one of the best and
Mike Smith on them and the mile and a
half race almost becomes a half a mile
race that's that's what it is because
for the first mile you know whatever it
is Milan 70 yards it's it's just kind of
galloping along getting position he's
very tactical that being justified and I
think we're gonna have our second Triple
Crown winner in four years mmm not being
credible 37 year wait last time it would
just be just a couple for this time it's
unbelievable wait wait yeah I know and
it does it have to rain you think to be
your benefit you know what I'm tired of
the rain it's great look at trust me we
could run there if we can run the race
here at Vegas I'd be really happy I
could shack up with the Red Rock Resort
Casino and hotel and I could be there
and do my job I don't think my bosses
would be too pleased but look at please
I just won I'll be you know I'm gonna be
really I'm just gonna step I like 77 in
Sun that's it that's what I'd like okay
that's what I want I know
I'm just trying to pick it up his his
emmerich at the tables his dock there
because knowing him with his with his
sharp brain he'd be sitting there
counting cards daddy do you think he
count yeah right yeah he is
yeah he is Rain Man when he's around the
craft he's on his game dr. Emerich game
is crap no that just oh I don't think I
don't think Doc's ever picked up a pair
of dice serious hell is he picked up a
pair of cards I don't but I would like
to I would like to go play craps with
him I would I think he'd be I think he'd
be terrific he could go ahead and break
it down he picks up the dice he throws
eye hits the chips just nice not a hard
Eddy enjoy I enjoy listening to the call
chat again soon be well you got it
that's a neo chick right there on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience